[Music]
hello again and welcome to this episode
of what's up Prof hi Martin we're
continuing our Saga yeah well I hope the
people found the previous one
interesting and it was set out
quite straightforward it wasn't clouded
with all sorts of it's not
complicated and that we can make the
complex
one filled with less cobwebs that's
maybe we can just give a brief summary
of what we've discussed and just get the
intro into this and then we can pray
well we were talking about this woman
that rides the
Beast and we saw that she rides it
continually throughout all its stages
but there is is not stage when she has
no power when her secular Crown power is
taken away but she's but she's still
riding the Beastly so what is she riding
and who's doing her bidding it must be a
proxy and that came out of the
bottomless pit now the only other
information we have about where where a
philosophy comes out of the bottomless
pit is in Revelation 11 when France went
directly against the
Scriptures it did all the things that
were necessary post that through
Napoleon it legalized all religions put
them on the same footing no
discrimination
anymore but at the same time there was a
massive drive to discredit the
scriptures that's it and you had the
rise of uh the higher critical movements
reason and you had the Age of
Reason and uh all those jesuitical
philosophy opers like Vol Vol and all of
them were instrumental in making the
Bible a book of myths yeah discrediting
it making it seem
disjointed when we can see This
Magnificent Harmony that the reformers
had discovered yeah but which had to be
buried under a pile of rubbish and
through jesuitical theories and
diabolical abominable
uh
doctrines they had destroyed yeah the
whole thinking of the reformation and
took the heat away from the true
identity of the woman and the Beast and
instead of going with the biblical flow
from literal Israel to spiritual Israel
they reintroduced literal Israel and
changed the entire religious thinking of
the Protestant world it is a horrendous
situation and may God give us wisdom
to determine this travesty of Justice
amen and may we try and put it back to
where it should the focus should be
let's put it back so let's pray before
we start with this one our heavenly
father thank you so much that we can
have a opportunity to do this discussion
we need such Clarity that only you can
give so please enlighten our minds with
the Holy Spirit and also the viewers in
Jesus name amen amen
so five had fallen one
is and nobody knows that she's ruling
because she doesn't have any crowns
she's from the bottomless pit so the
philosophy that she is propagating is a
bottomless pit
philosophy uh dressed up like a lambik
philosophy yeah it's a very sad State of
Affairs so what we have in this sixth
Beast m
is a situation
where uh there are philosophies that are
talking against each other mhm because
the dragon philosophy is the church
rules and our dogmas stand the other
philosophy is the church is totally
removed from government and has no say
whatsoever and in any case if you want
to base it on the Bible the Bible is a
discredited book correct nobody believes
Genesis they made sure
1844 that the theory of evolution took
care of that then the higher critics
took care of the rest yeah and in the
end you believe nothing at all and then
you have a false doctrine of
literalizing that which is passed and
you have the whole question of
dispensationalism literal Israel and
then you're looking for literal Wars and
situations and an antichrist in the
future correct so let's continue with
this with this
Saga so in Daniel 11:40 we read and at
the time of the end shall the King of
the South push at him at the King of the
North that is the
papacy and the King of the North shall
come against him like a whirlwind so at
the time of the end 1798 is's going to
push at him and he's going to subdue him
MH but that will be overcome and
eventually the King of the North will
come against him like a
whirlwind that means very rapidly Martin
yeah with chariots and Horsemen and many
ships he's going to use the economy he's
even going to use military power he's
going to use everything at his disposal
and he's going to make sure that this
King of the South philosophy is set
aside because he's allowed it to go so
far that it becomes debauched yeah which
is what we see and we spoke about it in
our previous one not the one before this
but the one before that yes about the
setting up of the image of the beast
that's it and then he shall enter into
the countries and shall overflow and
pass over it's going to be a worldwide
Rush yeah this is where it's going to go
and it's also going to be rapid yes now
we had this slide in the previous one
the one that he's using as a proxy is
the Beast out of the earth there are no
crowns on any of these horns the Beast
has two phases a lambik phase and a
phase that speaks like a dragon right
the dragon is Rome yeah so we want to go
back to the King of the North philosophy
that is Roman philosophy and we want to
overcome the secular philosophy that is
ruling now let's put it this way in a
political sense the Republicans are
going to have to overcome the Democrat
way of thinking that's it that's where
it comes from it comes so you have to
get rid of woke you have to bring back
religious uh ideologies and then you
have to have the church enforce their
dogmas because they don't want to sit
with this old system anymore and they
can only do that through legislation at
this by the state correct and I beheld
another Beast come up out of the earth
and it had two horns like a lamb and it
spoke like a dragon so it seems like a
lamb-like beast but it will speak like
Rome
spoke and he exercises all the power of
the first Beast before him so he's a
proxy
yeah and causes the Earth and them that
dwell therein to worship the first Beast
whose deadly wound was healed so he's
acting on behalf of the first beast
that's it now nobody in the United
States of America will want to believe
that they will say that the Protestant
Founders they set up this beautiful
system and that Rome had nothing to do
with it well we'll have to look at that
in a little bit more detail because that
we saw in the previous one the freedom
of religion was in brought about by
Napoleon yes and Liberty fraternity and
all of these things and who sent the
Statue of Liberty to the United States
France France now in the very year that
the first Beast received its wound yeah
when the Pope's secular power was taken
away in that very same year France
recognized the sovereignty of the United
States of America same year and they
sent them the Statue of Liberty now that
Statue of Liberty is actually a statue
of the god Mitra yeah and it's actually
if you go a little bit
deeper the the lightbearer which is
Lucifer but uh let's not go into all of
those details so the proxy is the United
States now how did this come about out
is it possible that in the E not stage
of the Beast of
Revelation
17 he is ruling via a proxy
mhm well let's reason together about
this let's have a look at this
undercover enemy remember that tapa
sorus said in his rulers of evil that
the Jesuits were actually in control of
American history and nobody knows
anything about it yeah yeah and uh
President Clinton is accredited with
saying the worst thing you can do in
life is to underestimate your adversary
it's a very dangerous thing did the
reformers know who the enemy was yes for
sure did they underestimate him yes it's
the same almost the same keep your
friends close but your enemy closer that
you can study him and know exactly what
he's saying yes now the other thing I
thought I was going to be a bit naughty
and put my own quote in there uh just as
a little bit of a counter and I thought
it would be nice to say the best thing
you can do in life is to know which side
you are on and why yeah in other words
you must study these things Martin you
can't just know your adversary you
mustn't underestimate your adversary but
you must know why is the adversary and
If he if you are convinced he is the
adversary you must know which side you
are
on and and you must know why you're on
that side and unfortunately there's not
a state of not deciding which side
you're on if you don't decide the one
you obviously go over to the other you
really are between what they say a rock
and a hard place you have to make a
decision
here Pat Shannon the investigative
journalist to wrote the forward to tapa
Sour's book rulers of evil sti's
prosecutor was a Jesuit priest employed
in the Justice Department as an
assistant United States Attorney soury
devoted his fugitive years 10 of them to
studying the extent of Jesuit
involvement in the United States
government both presently and
historically I'm we're putting this
slide in to recap what we said before
just to get us on the same page again
and to do a little bit of um putting it
everything into perspective correct his
labors have rewarded us with valuable
new proofs of a vast Roman Catholic
substratum to American history that
nobody knows about Mar evidence suggests
that Jesuits played an eminent and
underappreciated roles in moving the
complacent new englanders to rebel
against their mother country in
1776 so here was a movement to create a
new country mhm with total freedom of
religion where no religion could be
banned and therefore the Jesuits could
operate freely un opposed mhm they set
up the entire schooling system of the
nation yeah today the presidents are
educated at the foram and Jesuit
universities like um Georgetown to
University all of these things they are
totally in control not only that they
have slipped into roles that nobody even
knows they're there they're like snakes
in a burrow oh and it doesn't matter
which side of the political
divide like the Jesuit educators of the
presidents have said quite
plainly that the two political parties
are not there to change any policy even
though they are playing north south
competition they're actually sitting at
the same table plotting these things
that's it well even the book of the
Bible tells us the same yes now this
same man Pat Shannon also wrote that the
only people in the world it seems who
believe in the conspiracy theory of
history or those of us who have studied
it so Martin that's quite a compliment
because if you're called the
conspiracist if you're called the Bible
conspiracist so much the
better now in Taka Carlson's interview
with Putin that was a very interesting
interview right interesting caused a lot
of waves yeah yeah and I think one of
the things was that caused a lot of
waves is he let Putin speak yes it was
clearly eluded that the presidents of
the United States are powerless to make
decision decisions and the real power
lies in the intelligence arm of the
United States the
CIA the CIA was founded by the all
powerful intelligence arm of the Roman
Catholic Church run by the Knights of
Malta and the Jesuits that's just common
history
mhm let's just listen to that at a
meeting here in the Kremlin with the
outgoing President Bill Clinton right
here in the next room I said to him I
asked him
Bill do you think if Russia asked to
join NATO do you think it would
happen suddenly he said you know it's
interesting I think
so but in the evening when we met for
dinner he said you know I've talked to
my team no no it's not possible
now you can ask him I think he will
watch our interview he'll confirm it I
repeatedly raised the issue that the
United States should not support
separatism or terrorism in the north
Caucasus but they continue to do it
anyway and political support information
support financial support even Military
Support came from the United States and
its satellites for terrorist groups in
the
Caucasus I once raised this issue with
my colleague also the president of the
United States he says it's possible do
you have proof I said yes I said to the
FSB director write to the CIA what is
the result of the conversation with
President he wrote once twice and then
we got a
reply we have the answer in the arive
the CIA replied we have been working
with the opposition in Russia we believe
that this is the right thing to do and
we will keep on doing it twice you've
described us president's making
decisions and then being undercut by
their agency heads so it sounds like
you're describing a system that's not
run by the people who are elected in
your
telling that's right that's
right in the end they just toldo us to
get lost so Mar he says that the CIA is
actually in control so the Secret
Service actually wields a lot of power
right mhm let's just go back to the book
The great
controversy and see what it says there
God's word has given warning of the
impending danger let this be unheeded
and the Protestant world will learn what
the purposes of Rome really are only
when it is too late to escape the snare
now M if there is a
snare then Rome must somehow have power
that they don't know about right yeah
because it's not visible yes
she is silently growing into Power her
doctrines are exerting their influence
in legislative halls in churches in the
hearts of men she's piling up her lofty
and massive structures in the secret
recesses of which her former persecution
will be repeated
stealthily
unsuspectedly she is strengthening her
forces to further our own ends and when
the time comes for her to strike now
this must be in the United States
obviously she's not building these
structures in other countries she's
obviously also building them there but
here concerning the United States this
is happening in the United States this
is showing that the proxy this is she's
underground
underground all that she desires is vage
ground and this already is being given
her we shall soon see and shall feel
what the purpose of the RO element is
whoever Shall Believe and obey the word
of God will thereby incur the reproach
and persecution so we're going to have a
conflict and very clearly it says who
the enemy is it's papacy in Rome yes so
here you have a beautiful sunset over
the
Vatican but the Vatican doesn't Only
Rule from the Vatican Martin yeah it
rules from the very Nations that it used
to control and all the others as well
and like one of the Jesuit generals says
nobody knows how it's done yeah why even
China is subject to them why is it that
China pays huge sums of money over to
the Vatican is it to support them or is
it to pay a Debt Pay a debt that it is a
was it a Jesuit that said from this
window I Ru
yes but it's also interesting that
Sunset if you look close uh quickly you
can mistake it for the capital ah it
looks very very similar yes the image of
the Beast now here is a Jesuit uh
structure in Rome so it has the symbol
of the Jesuits IHS over there and on
either side they have these symbols over
here this is the
kza of St ignatio
deola he was the the Church of ignasius
of Lola and he was the founder of the
Jesuit order yes he together with Peta
Faba and Francis
Xavier and Francis Xavier is the one who
introduced the Inquisition in Goa
because there were the thomasites
Christians that were keeping the the
Sabbath and he wanted to get rid of that
and paba was the one who introduced the
philosophy he was The
Thinker now interesting that they make
no bones about their feelings about
suppressing other
churches because there they have those
two images over there or statues and
I've enlarged them and you can see them
standing the Jesuit order is here Christ
cring The Woman Under Foot they are
crushing out protestantism they're not
ashamed of it no they are not ashamed of
it they are blatantly advertising it
let's see what else they
advertise right next door to this
building is the Supreme Council of the
Masonic Lodge in Italy is that a
coincidence oh that must be a complete
coincidence that it would be right next
to the Jesuit Enclave now interestingly
enough when you read their plaque over
here they have these three dots in
between their letters and those three
dots are a signatory of the Jesuit
order whenever a Jesuit signs he will
put those three dots there and then of
course they have the double-headed eagle
with the 33° Masonic sign over
there and this headquarter
is right next to the Jesuit seat of
power yeah I don't think it's pure
coincidence Martin pure
coincidence if you enter the churches of
the Jesuits you will immediately see
what they are portraying here you have
the woman with a golden cup in her hand
mhm that is Rome Romey and she's the one
that writes the Beast according to
Revelation and they are proud of it and
here are the kings of the world with
their crowns on their heads at her feet
adoring her mhm wondering wondering
after the beast but anybody who is not
quite in tune is falling away and being
eliminated you're either with me or you
are against me if you are not with me I
will kill you yeah right so you have the
kings of the world commit fornication
with her is that what they're portraying
here oh for sure here again you have the
depiction of the woman with the golden
cup in her hand whether this is
masculine or feminine doesn't matter
because they're very androgenic mhm very
androgenic and here's another
interesting statue that they have over
here here you have the woman with a
lightning bolt yeah that in her hand now
the lightning bolt was the symbol of zus
mhm and Zas was the main god and he's a
symbol of Lucifer the lightbearer and
with the lightning bolt he gets rid of
his enemies he strikes them with his
lightning
right he's also the god Tor god of
thunder and here this woman is using the
cross which has nothing to do with
Christianity in this case this has to do
with wielding a power in the so-called
name of Christianity that's it but it's
actually the Egyptian ank probably or
the tow mhm and here he is this woman is
obliterating two
individuals and the one is Calvin and
the other one is Martin
Luther so in other words they're
obliterating the Protestant Reformation
they did a good job with that oh for
sure and they that that they didn't
obliterate they Incorporated correct and
then on the other side you have this
little
Angel and he's tearing the pages I've
enlarged him here a little bit there you
can see the angel ripping out the pages
of this book that's the writing of
Martin Luther now what is the most
famous work of Martin
Luther well the Bible that he translated
ah let's rip it apart Martin let's use
higher criticism and the theory of
evolution and let the Jesuits introduce
the Big Bang Theory that Big Bang Theory
will explode in their face like a big
bang at some stage they're going to have
their own little mushroom they're going
to have to account for it and go to
petion well uh I think this is pretty
clear what they are trying to portray
and what they are trying to say there's
a little interesting tidbit of
History this is the Museo National
Castel s
Angelo now this used to be a Garrison at
some stage but it also became a or a
fortress it also became a jail mhm where
High political prisoners or religious
prisoners were held now it has a very
very interesting history and if you take
a little uh look from another angle you
will see here is this building and over
there in the background is the
Vatican now what most people don't
necessarily know is that there was a
secret
connection between the two yeah so you
could walk from the one to the other
unnoticed mhm so if you were imprisoned
here or supposedly imprisoned here you
could still have contact with whatever
was taking place in the Vatican now
there was a very famous prisoner in here
because when the papacy received a
mortal wound in
1798 the Jesuits also received the
Mortal wound or seemingly that seemingly
received the Mortal wound they were
banned in almost every country in Europe
because of their
activities and they couldn't operate as
freely as they wanted so you know if you
are in this in the in the Spy World and
the heat is on why not seemingly kill
yourself best way just get the heat away
from then it can't be you right so the
pope can't be the Antichrist he's dead
yeah and the Jesuits can't be the
problem they've been banned they've been
disbanded they're gone
yeah so even the pope disbanded the
Jesuits and the Jesuit General
Ricky was taken into
custody and apparently died in this very
very
place now let's read about these things
this comes from the book
rulers of evil and this is Lorenzo Ricky
Society of Jesus General in this very
very interesting time in
history if the Society of Jesus could
conquer though believed dead could not
its Superior General do the
same when Lorenzo Ricky died in his cell
at Castell St Angelo on November the
24th 17
1975 what if his death was no more
physical than the supposed
disestablishment of his
army lesser Mystics than Ricky who
secretly commanded the rosicrucians were
known to die and resurrect at the
threshold of important
Endeavors what if it was expedient that
the world should think that with General
Ricky the Jesuit order had disappeared
very it takes all the attention away
what if it seemed to have a Mor but
didn't have
one and if you take it what if it then
still is ah what if it is not but
actually is still ruling because the
woman is still riding the beast and what
if the philosophy is the philosophy of
the French Revolution yeah and that is
the destruction of the scriptures and
the that comes from the bottomless bit
it comes from the bottomless bit so here
we continue with this story during the
fall of
1775 Congress in the United States
authorized the committee made up of
Benjamin Franklin Thomas Lynch Benjamin
Harrison and George Washington
Freemasons all of them to consider and
recommend a design for the first United
Colonial
flag the so-called flag committee they
traveled to Cambridge Massachusetts
there according to the only known
account of its proceedings given in
Robert Allan Campbell's book our flag
written in 1890 the committee
mysteriously shared its Authority with a
total
stranger this stranger was an elderly
European transient known only as the
professor he had arrived from Parts
Unknown at Summer's end the prisoner of
Castel St Angelo had not been publicly
seen in two years ample time to manage
brasi's election to the papacy relax
pack important things die the
Philosopher's death and take a three
Monon Voyage to Boston Harbor
interesting Martin if he was banned and
he was a prisoner and his whole
organization was disbanded why when they
so-called buried him MH was he given
full honor yeah shouldn't he have just
been buried ignon yeah for sure because
the he was a a heretic you can almost
say he was an evil man why was he given
full honors very strange I believe they
buried a pile of stones in a coffin and
since his arrival the Prof Professor had
occupied a guest room in a private
Cambridge home whose Hostess one of his
Earnest and intelligent disciples would
remember him in a diary cited in
campell's book as a quiet and very
interesting memory of the
family there's a story usually told in
conjunction with the professor and the
flag committee involving another
mysterious stranger one who suddenly
appeared in the legislative chamber of
the old State House in Philadelphia on
the night of July the 4th the moment was
tense Independence had been resolved but
the document lacked signatures some were
having second thoughts about the risks
Masonic historian manle P hall
writes it was a grave moment and not a
few of those present feared that their
lives would be the forfeit for their
audacity this is the independence of the
United States from Britain yes so their
audacity would is that Independence to
declare independence in the midst of the
debate a fierce voice rang out the
debator stopped and turned to look upon
the stranger who was this man who had
suddenly appeared in their midst and
transfixed them with his
oratory they had never seen him before
none knew when he had entered but his
tall form and pale face filled them with
all his voice ringing with holy Zeal The
Strangers stirred them to their very
Souls his closing words rang through the
building God has given America to be
free as the stranger sank into a chair
exhausted a wild enthusiasm burst forth
name after name was placed upon the
parchment the Declaration of
Independence was signed but where was
the man who had precipitated the
accomplishment of this Immortal task who
had lifted for a moment the veil from
the eyes of the assemblage and revealed
to them part at least of the great
purpose for which the new nation was
conceived he had disappeared nor was he
ever seen again or his identity
established so this comes from manly
pahal the secret
teachings but was this the
general and why is it that the seat of
the American government is in Maryland
yeah and Maryland belonged to the
Jesuits so the very seat of government
is on Jesuit land that's it it's
interesting if you go to our own country
South
Africa there was an argument the other
day why Parliament should tolerate a
masonic lodge on its ground and then and
then it was interestingly stated sorry
it's the other way around Parliament is
on the Masonic lodges ground who
controls the
governments the Jesuits via the secret
societies so who are these secret
societies well this was the General at
the time when Benedict ruled this is
Festa and here are the top Knights of
Malta they are if they become the
general they are also of Royal lineage
they always Royal mhm so they called his
Royal
Highness and they are totally
subservient to the
pope now the Jesuits of course control
the Knights of Malta yeah but nobody
really knows that because this is the
oldest military
order that exists in the Roman Catholic
church so let's just make sure of these
issues here is an article from
2023 comes from Vatican news Pope To
Order of Malta go forth in your mission
while remaining faithful to Christ when
you see Christ substitute the Catholic
church that's how they they mean mean
that's what they mean so here the pope
visited Malta Pope Francis addresses The
Sovereign Order of Malta at the
conclusion of their General chapter and
encourage them them to go forth in their
mission of after the election of new
high officers while remaining always
faithful to Christ substitute the Roman
Catholic Church that's it now he totally
reorganized the order very interesting
so let's read further in Vatican news
Pope To Order of Malta go forth on your
mission while remaining faithful to
Christ he talked about them being
Sovereign beginning with the term
sovereign Pope Francis noted that this
is a very singular
sovereignty assumed over the centuries
more than a thousand years in fact and
confirmed by the will of the popes it
allows you to make generous and
demanding gestures of
solidarity making yourselves close to
those most in need under interational
diplomatic legal
protection so you're untouchable yeah
Untouchable and they have to be subject
to the pope totally subservient to the
pope now this pope of course is a Jesuit
right MH and then he referred to their
military
status so they entitled to make war yeah
make war on whom Martin on the remnant
of her seed ah and on protestantism
that's it because he persecuted the
woman that's where it started so Pope
Francis then went on to speak of the
word
military for the defenses of pilgrims
and holy places as well as
Christianity
papacy your order has written glorious
pages today those deeds give way to
interreligious dialogue moreover faith
in Christ and the following of him
commit you to the witness of the gospel
and to fight against everything that
opposes
it uh if we can rephrase that you know
what we've actually beaten the
Protestants yeah we've destroyed them so
now we are moving into the
interreligious dialogue phase yeah we
are going to set up a new
structure and you will fight against
anything that opposes that because you
are obedient to the pope and to the
church yeah we'll code name that
Christ that's exactly what it's saying
that's what he's
saying now here's another article from
CNA which is the Catholic news
agency how did Pope Francis change the
Order of Malta so he actually yeah so he
changed it a bit yeah when September the
6th 2022 that's pretty recent isn't it
exactly they must be getting somewhere
in their agenda um maybe moving towards
a wound that is healed
ah the holy Sea and the pope are
pervasive
according to articles 6 and 14 the pope
is the
co-regulator all members of the order of
Malto are directly subject to him that
makes it pretty
clear so who are they subject to to the
Jesuits yes because who's the Pope
subject to to the Jesuit to the black
pope he a Jesuit and he's a Jesuit
himself and he a Jesuit himself so under
the old Constitution the members of the
order enjoyed a certain autonomy uhhuh
so if that was previous now they don't
now they have to jump now the this order
has a massive budget of billions of
dollars and it has of course priests and
prelates that are in it but it has a
huge secular arm exactly secular and and
they're all sworn to obedience to the
pope presidents as well and now if you
belong to this Order of
Malta then you are subject to the pope
now I've shown many slides in the past
of presidents in the world including
Nelson Mandela of South Africa or his uh
subsequent follower uh Becky or any of
the others they're all involved in these
secret
societies what did you have to say about
Joe Biden I've SE I've read an article
that that he in the Jesuit uh magazine
America that he's also a knight of Malta
ah so if he's a knight of Malta is he
playing a role is he playing it well
definitely isn't he playing the role of
the King of the South he's playing the
role of the King of the South but if you
go to the other
presidents the Skull and Bones guys are
almost in the same they're all in the
same situation so now you will do
exactly what you are told we're in a new
era we are moving to the stage when the
wound will be healed yeah here's the
Times of Malta the new Grand Master of
the Order of Malta is sworn in and the
date was the 4th of May
2023 so the order has been brought in
line with current Necessities exactly
it's been you remember that um Pope
Francis
also a few years back he re shifted his
um Cardinals and everybody and
everywhere he put in Jesuits correct so
here is fr John Dunlop a 66y old
Canadian he's actually a lawyer and he's
been elected Prince remember he a royal
and 81st grandm of The Sovereign
military Order of Malta he is the first
professed knight from the Americas to be
elected as head of the order uh they
must be expecting something important
going down getting ready for the he
wound to be completely he and he's a
Canadian now the Canadians have been
very good as playing King of the South
philosophy and uh trau has been very
instrumental in that and everybody is
riled up against it and the King of the
North philosophy says this can no longer
continue right so we need a man on the
ground it's almost like the King of the
South pushing the King of the North is
getting ready to come he's getting ready
he's setting up his military strategy
now what wonderful work did they do in
the past that he referred to well the
CIA who formed the CIA it was a Catholic
Knight of Malta William Wild Bill
Donovan he was considered the father of
the CIA was also the former head of the
OSS before he was used to create the CIA
and the CIA is
run by the of maltas and other secret
society it is riddled with Freemasonry
and secret society including Knights of
the Columba Columbus and all of this
what about the FBI who formed the FBI it
was a powerful Roman Catholic who was
also a knight of Malta and a trustee of
the Catholic University of America
Charles Joseph
Bonaparte I wonder whether those names
are coincidental Martin um no I don't
think so so the CIA and the FBI are run
by the kns of Malta to this very day the
Supreme Court has been loaded with
Catholic individuals they are totally in
control her structures have been set up
she's ready to strike exactly and she's
going to use her proxy yep and who is
that United States of America United
States of
America now let's ask a few questions
could the lambl likee Beast Be a proxy
of the Jesuits certainly seems like
it one
is that's the six head because five had
fallen right
y the founding fathers were Freemasons
heavily influenced by the jesuitical
teachings of the French
Revolution a separation of church and
state morphing into a secular
socialistic humanistic form of
government represented by the King of
the South philosophy is that what
Napoleon set up that's for sure is that
what they transferred to the United
States yes is that what was written into
the constitution in such a way that
nobody would notice it exactly and they
think that it is Christian in the
meanwhile it's secularism is it written
in such a way that they can now
reinterpret it yes hasn't the Speaker of
the House said it must be reinterpreted
they did he said that there's nothing
stating that it should be separate
okay so opposed to this philosophy of
the South you have the philosophy of the
King of the North that the papacy
wielded throughout the Dark Ages and
seek to reinstate in the near future
because the wound must heal right that's
it when the lambik Beast starts speaking
as a
dragon and the King of the South
philosophy is
overrun then the image of the Beast will
have formed as the head is that correct
yes and this will lead to the
resurrection of the Pope as the eighth
head that belongs to the seven CU it's
one and the same he's ruling them all
he's a and the Seven is a proxy is still
ruled by the woman yes so five have
fallen Babylon me Persia Greece and Rome
Babylon was overcome militarily by Meo
Persia which was overcome militar by
Greece which was overcome militarily by
Rome and since then there's been no such
conquering but just a change in Phase
that's it a shift so Pagan Rome morphed
into Pap Rome one is Fallen Rome ruling
through the lambl likee beast in secret
societies
MH not yet come lambik beasts speaking
like a dragon fortunately the Bible says
for a little while yeah because this is
the end of the matter and that's again a
movement is it fair of God MH to say I
will only permit you for a little while
yes why because the Reformation made it
quite clear who the enemy is is it the
Reformation defined wise doctrines were
wrong all of that has been swept under
the carpet a pagan philosophy has been
adopted the heat is of the
papacy Christianity is without an excuse
yeah God will see will you destroy true
Christianity will you destroy those who
love God and keep his Commandments I
just want to show it to the world we
will do exactly that yeah I will permit
it for a little while but I won't let
you go all the way I won't let that
happened what happened in the Middle
Ages and then there's the eighth Beast
that's the resurrected
papacy and it belongs to the seven
because it's one and the same thing the
others were just proxies still ruling
the woman also has a head and is thus
also the eighth head of the Beast the
system goes to pedition gets destroyed
it arises and then gets destroyed let's
have a look at that so the number eight
stands for a new
beginning circumcision was on the eth
day the New Testament connects
circumcision with baptism that's a new
beginning a new love cor yes in Exodus
22293 states that the first born was to
be given to God on the Eighth
Day Micah 5 verse 5 says and this man
shall be the peace when the Assyrian
shall come into our land that was just a
type of the Babylonian coming into the
land and when he shall tread in our
palaces then shall we raise against him
Seven Shepherds and eight principal
men so why seven and eight because
that's the number of Christ yeah both of
it both of them here's another one
Ecclesiastes 11:2 give a portion to
seven and also to eight for thou knowest
not what evil shall be upon the Earth
this number eight is a symbol of
completeness there's another example 1
Samuel 17:12 now David was the son of
the aphte of Bethlehem Judah whose name
was Jesse and he had eight
sons and Samuel went to anoint them and
he went through seven of them and he
said where's the other one the well the
youngest is out in the field go and
fetch him so he was the eighth and the
man went amongst men for an old man in
the days of
Saul but in Chronicles it's says and
Jesse beat the his first born iLab and
ABAB and the second Shima the thir and
nataniel the fourth and the the fth and
Azan the sixth and David the seventh now
what is he is he e or is he the seventh
so seven and8 together symbol symbolize
complete sufficiency MH in other words
it symbolizes a resurrection to
completeness that and if you are dead in
Christ then you will be resurrected or
raised in Christ and that like you
mentioned in that previous one it's like
the seventh day was the rest and the
eighth day was the Resurrection the new
beginning correct so let's let's
continue this study of Revelation 17 and
the 10 horns which thou sawest are 10
Kings which have received no Kingdom as
yet there are no crowns on their head
they are secular Powers but the woman is
still but the woman is controlling
without them knowing it through secret
societies yeah but they receive power as
kings one hour with the Beast so for a
short while they will again give the
power to the Beast and that means the
Beast must be resurrected it will rule
again that will be just before the vials
are poured out just before the vials are
poured out Revelation
17:13 these have one mind and shall give
their power and strength unto the
beast at the moment it's not there it's
but it's coming oh it's pushing we can
we show we showed it in that one where
we talked about the image of the
Beast they shall make war with the lamb
how do you make war with the Lamb by
attacking his people and attacking his
truth and the lamb Shall Overcome them
for he is Lord of lords and king of
kings and they that are with him are
called and chosen and faithful and he
said unto me the waters which thou
sawest where the sth are peoples
and multitudes and Nations and tongues
so the nations of the world Martin are
ruled by secret
societies and these secret societies are
all subject to Rome yeah whether we like
it or not that's the way it is what we
see now is a proxy rule it seems to have
a mortal wound it's and it first had to
destroy the last vestage of
protestantism before it could regain its
power so it also destroyed it by
infiltrating and getting it into it with
uh mingling with it whether you're
talking about Robert Schuler or whether
you're talking about any of these even
Billy Graham they were all
Masons they were all part of the system
and that's a very sad State of Affairs
but
fortunately for the scriptures and
unfortunately for this power there is
still a Remnant that refuses to
acknowledge Him that's that really bugs
him definitely and that's why he wants
this
power in order to get rid of them let's
look let's just make sure again about
these
associations remember that spoke about
them fraud runs through all these secret
associations and none can be bound up
with them and be free men before God and
Heaven the moral nature is dragged down
to that which God pronounces unjust
which is contrary to his will and his
Commandments one who professes to love
God May in these associations be placed
in positions which are called honorable
but in the eyes of God he has tarnished
his honor as a Christian and separating
father and father from the principles of
righteousness and true Holiness he is
perverting his powers that have been
purchased by the blood of Jesus he's
selling his soul for not is that serious
it is so serious because even though you
think or it looks to other people you
are doing God's work by associating you
there's no blessing God can can not let
it's not if you walk into a masonic
temple and there's an altar and the
Quran and the S Vita and the Bible and
the tanak and all of them are lying on
the table that is a pagan mwash yeah
isn't that what we've just read about um
what Napoleon did bring all religions on
the same level truth and error stand
next to each other no absolutely
not so in second manuscripts we read men
have confederated to oppose the Lord of
hosts these confederacies will continue
until Christ shall leave his place of
intercession before the mercy seat and
shall put on the garments of Vengeance
we're living in that time Mar with we're
this close for sure satanic agencies are
in how many
cities every city every city busily
organizing into parties that oppose to
the law of
God professed Saints and avowed
unbelievers take their stand with these
parties this is no time for the people
of God to be weaklings we cannot afford
to be off our God for a
moment get out of
ecumenical get up you cannot negotiate
with this enemy not at this stage in
history especially no so how's this
going to pan
out and the 10 horns which thou sawest
upon the Beast the shall hate the whall
Martin they were just of one mind yeah
they they just gave all their power and
were wondering after it they were
wondering after it they gave it all its
power and now all of a sudden they hate
the and shall make her desolate
and naked and shall eat her flesh and
burn her with
fire now that's very interesting because
the punishment for a for a
prostitute was stoning M unless she was
the daughter of a priest yeah then she
was burnt burnt now this is going
to be burnt so she must assume Priestly
power right this is the Roman Catholic
hierarchy and the kings of the world
will hate her what changes their mind
Martin they see that that it's it's lost
that they whole cause the whole of
Revelation 17 who told the story wasn't
it an angel with a vial in his hand
ready to pour it when those was the
plague yeah and here they were thinking
that they were doing the bidding of a
Godly thing and all of a sudden they're
hit by
plagues one plague two plagues three
plagues four plagues five
plagues six
plagues and they realize we're lost
we've been duped and their anger and
their animosity
Rises and they hate the and in
Every Nation they will attack her isn't
she a universal church yeah they will
burn her with fire they're going to
destroy her churches they're going to
rip them down they will rip them apart
with their bare hands if they can but
because they are eternally lost it's too
late it's too
late for God has put into their hearts
to fulfill his will his permissive will
mhm and to agree and give their Kingdom
unto the Beast they're going to give
them their power this is now before yes
they turn against it until the words of
God shall be F fed and who is this
woman she is that great City that reth
over the kings of the earth she's called
Babylon yeah but she sits on a Roman
beast that's it it's a very sad story
Martin this is the most serious story
and it's actually amazing how you can
see
this this move of it being fulfilled yes
now Martin the Bible says what has been
has been
before it's always been there in type we
are now living in the antitype yeah so
if we go to the book of Isaiah where it
Wars against uh literal
Babylon it's a type of what happens to
spiritual
Babylon come down and sit in the dust oh
virgin daughter of Babylon sit on the
ground there is no
Throne a throne is going to be
removed oh daughter of the
calans who are the modern day calans the
Jesuits for Thou shalt no more be called
tender and
delicate and then from verse 11
therefore shall evil come upon thee Thou
shalt not know from whence it
rises Mischief shall fall upon thee Thou
shalt not be able to put it off and
desolation shall come upon thee suddenly
which Thou shalt not know stand now with
thine
enchantments and with a multitude of thy
sorceries wherein thou has labored from
thy youth if so be thou shalt be able to
profit if so be thou mayest Prevail Thou
Art wearied in the multitude of thy
counsels let now the astrologers and the
stargazers and the monthly prognostic
Ator stand up and save thee from these
things that shall come upon you she's
going to be destroyed completely
completely and utterly and this is
exactly what's going to happen to this
system behold there shall be a
stubble the fire shall burn them isn't
that what happens to her she is burnt
with fire
ashes they shall not deliver themselves
from the power of the flame there shall
not be a coal to warm at nor a fire to
sit before it
thus shall they be unto thee with whom
thou Hast labored even thy
Merchants from thy youth they shall
wander everyone to his quarter and None
Shall save
thee through her secret
societies through her socalled
philanthropic multi-billionaires MH MH
she controls the entire economy yeah she
owns the banks of the world the banking
system the Rothchilds the Bank of
America she is the one that calls the
shots the
militaries and Revelation 18 tells us
the same thing how much she has
glorified herself and lived
deliciously so much torment and sorrow
give her for she says in her heart I sit
a queen I am not a widow I shall see no
sorrow so she's very boastful very
boastful did we see those statues oh
yeah
therefore shall our plagues come in one
day death and mourning and famine can
you see that it's plagues yeah yes and
she shall be utterly burned with fire
same
story strong is the Lord God who judges
her and the kings of the earth who have
committed fornication and live
deliciously with her shall be wail her
and lament for her when they shall see
the smoke of her burning they're
permited to live a little longer and
then they are destroyed by the
brightness of his coming doesn't Psalms
110 say that he will destroy Kings MH
when he comes he will fill the places
with dead bodies yeah Martin there's a
terrible judgment coming that's it
terrible so you can decide you still
have a choice now you still have a
choice so let's wrap this up when the
leading churches of the United States
uniting upon such points of Doctrine as
are held by them in common shall
influence the state to enforce their
decrees and to sustain their
institutions then Protestant America
will have formed an image of the Roman
hierarchy and the infliction of civil
penalties upon denters will inevitably
result that's what's going to happen and
that's it and this okay we might just
say can be done by either the the
Republicans or the democ done to me
logically the Republican side seems
logical but history will be fulfilled
and prophecy will be fulfilled with or
without them even if the stones have to
do it because the only thing that really
has to happen they have to go they have
to do the bidding of Rome so who it does
doesn't matter correct all right there's
another quote from five
testimonies when our nation shall so
abjure the principles of its government
as to enact the Sunday law protestantism
will in this act join hands with poery
it will be nothing else than giving life
to the Tyranny which has long been
eagerly watching its opportunity to
Spring again into active
despotism so something's going to happen
there another statement from the great
controversy when the early church became
corrupted by departing from the
Simplicity of the gospel and accepting
Heathen rights and
Customs she lost the spirit and power of
God and in order to control the
consciences of the people she sought the
support of the secular power the result
was the papacy a church that controlled
the power of the state and employed it
to further her own ends is especially
for the punishment of
heresy in order for the United States to
form an image of the Beast the religious
power must so control the civil
government that the authority of the
state will be employed by the church to
accomplish our own ends is that clear
it's clear and as we read this I get the
pictures that we showed in two episodes
again ago yes it's happening it's
happening there's an article from the
review and Herald many will plead that
there is no prospect that popery will
ever be
revived if it shall regain its lost
ascendancy it will be by Protestant ISM
giving at the right hand of Fellowship
so the Beast out of the earth is
actually responsible for the
resurrection of the first Beast yes but
the first Beast is actually controlling
the politics of the Beast out of the
earth
yes it's because the woman rides the
beast that's it it's a perfect
proxy it shall be legislated into Power
by the concessions of time serving
men they don't know what's going going
on they go with a
flow the fires of persecution will be
rekindled against those who will not
sacrifice conscience and the truth for
the errors of
papacy once let the minds of the
Christian World be turned away from God
let his law be Dishonored and His holy
day trampled upon and they will be ready
to take any step where Satan may lead
the
way so Martin we showed in our previous
one or one of the previous ones that
Trump promises a Revival of Christian
power in speech to National Religious
broadcasters if I get in you're going to
be using that power at a level you never
used it before is that the church
dictating to the state for sure Trump
told the annual Gathering of National
Religious
broadcasters at Nashville's Gaylord opr
land Resort and Convention Center he
told the religious
broadcasters that one of his first acts
of a second Trump term would be to set
up a task force to root out
anti-christian bias root it out that is
is that speaking like a dragon
oh perfectly I will be a peacemaker
that's how you can twist it that's it
and I will be the only president who can
say and I say this with great conviction
I will prevent World War II in actual
fact he said that he will reverse the
Border crisis M and get rid of the
murderers that are killing the young
women in the United States he will re-
uh connect the economy so that inflation
is turned around he will prevent World
War II MH and he will reinstate the
church
through sorry through legislation
through legislation we have to bring
back our religion he said we have to
bring back
Christianity uh that's creating the
image to the Beast now though she leads
the United States this is going to
happen everywhere right yes is the world
getting ready for it to happen
everywhere well it's very interesting if
you take these statements that you just
made and you take the spirit of Prophecy
statement how it's fulfilling it's stuff
tailing and then of course
2025 and this nationalism project and
how many right-wing organization have
signed this project
2025 and how they're going to bring it
in under the heading big picture the
manifesto claims to affirm that this
Christian nationalist project entails
National recognition of essential
Christian
Orthodoxy that's enforcing
dogmas just like Pap roamed it in the
Middle Ages so persecution will be
rekindled as a Christian consent under
Jesus Christ the Supreme Lord and king
of all creation no under the papacy yeah
and we forget that Christians were
persecuted under the Christian papal
rule yes and the establishment of
General Equity of the Ten Commandments
as the foundational law of the nation no
papal Ten Commandments that means Sunday
law and not seventh day Sabbath the
whole thing is there this is not not
fooling around this is very
serious now what about the rest of the
world here's an
article and it's brand new hungary's
Orban vows search to the right in us and
Europe Hungarian prime minister Victor
Orban has told the crowd of cheering
supporters that his government's
nationalist conservative policies will
win this year in Europe and Beyond mhm
we started this year Alone by the end of
it we will be the majority in the world
he said in
Budapest he was confident Donald Trump
would win November's US presidential
election and right-wing parties would
win European Parliament elections in
June man is the world ready for this oh
for sure and Putin is a friend of this
guy and so yes Putin is the friend of
this man here we go Martin
the stage you set so where does that
leave us when the protection of human
laws shall be withdrawn from those who
honor the law of God there will be in
different lands did we just see that
right across the world a simultaneous
movement are we seeing that oh yeah for
their
destruction that's
interesting at the time appointed in the
decree draws near the people will
conspire to root out the hated sect it
will be determined to strike in one
night a decisive blow which shall
utterly silence the voice of dissent and
Repro that sounds like a bolom unite
yeah like in France when they said in
one night we will destroy the
Protestants and what did Rome do they
rang the bells and were Overjoyed that
the Protestants had been slaughtered and
murdered yeah so it was Christian
killing Christian and who's the enemy
Revelation 14:12 he is the patience of
the Saints here are they that keep the
Commandments of God and the faith of
Jesus they are rooted in what Jesus says
in his
word Thy word is a lamp unto my feet and
a light unto my path man does not live
by bread alone but by every word that
proceeds out of the mouth of the
Lord and Martin they keep the
Commandments of God and refuse to adhere
to the Commandments of the Pope yeah and
they will be the enemy because this will
be the last attempt of Satan to rid the
world of any opposition to his
Rule and God will permit it to a point
just a short time but for a short time
just to demonstrate that Rebellion is
incurable but for don't think for a
moment it's not going to be a fierce
time it's going to be a fierce battle
and we are just before it Revelation
17 has almost reached its
culmination and I believe it can reach
it within
months maybe a year it's interesting
that Donald Trump said it will be
decided on November the
5th Now isn't November the 5th guy fox
day yeah what happened that guy Fox
Martin they tried to get rid a blow up
the parliament to get rid of the King
James Bible ah to get rid of the Bible
and Protestant
Rule and are they going to blow up the
parliament in an anti-typical Fashion on
November the 5th and set up papal
Supremacy again and Resurrect The
eth I think it's going to be interesting
I think we're heading for it let's pray
that the Lord preserves us amen let's
bring a loud cry let's pray Heavenly
Father what a story all depicted there
in the
Bible and we are reading it now in the
pages of history and seeing the
culmination
thereof and multitudes multitudes in the
valley of
decision who's going to reach them who's
going to tell them who's going to warn
them
if the loud cry does not go
out Humanity will not know and run over
the
precipice help us to give them a choice
so that at least some turn from the
precipice is my prayer in jesus' name
amen
[Music]